what do you say chaos a gaping pit
waiting to swallow us all chaos isn't a
pit chaos is our ladder
what do you see so everybody was
messaging me yesterday about the episode
for League typically I have to wait for
the dust to settle on situations where
the FBI gets involved so this is just be
an explainer for what's going on what
all the craziness is about just a
reminder to please not post spoilers
from the episode on this video I'll post
that video tomorrow we can talk all
about the episode the stuff that happens
during it no problem but if you were a
human on the internet yesterday you
probably saw that an entire episode of
Game of Thrones leaked just like it did
back during season five but that was a
little bit more serious this past week
there were two separate things that
happen two completely different groups
hacked HBO's separately one was HBO
proper in the United States they were
going after a mountain of data Sony
style if you remember the Sony hack they
blame North Korea for hacking Sony
servers they released mountains and
mountains of confidential data it was
stuff about how much actors earned it
was stuff about the projects they were
working on there were all these emails
that they leaked that was the big HBO
hack that was reported this past week
way over on the other side of the earth
a completely separate group hacked HBO's
India affiliate and released an episode
that had been given to them in advance
of it airing so they get early episodes
somebody just found it on one of their
servers and uploaded it to the Internet
so when you hear about the episode
League that's what they are talking
about the HBO hack is a completely
separate thing so the people going after
data the people going after the episode
were two completely different groups
you've also probably seen by now that
anybody that did a game of Thrones video
yesterday about anything just had like a
bunch of spoiler thumbnails next to it
because people started uploading it to
YouTube most of those people have since
been banned by HBO which is typically
why you don't see me doing videos or
jumping on stuff like that because the
leak came from inside India that's where
I saw most of the comments coming from
really early in the day like hey have
you seen this do you know what's going
on so big shout out to you guys but
within about a half an hour that had
spread around the world so was this big
dance that everybody was doing you know
do we partake in this do we just ignore
it because the episode is going to air
in a couple days anyway so for the most
part I think that people did not partake
but it's just like a small fry
to people that watch my videos that
comment on it so most of the people
commenting we're people that actually
did watch the episode so no judging
everybody's free to do as they please
but usually when like big leaks like
that happen people don't immediately
want spoilers so I try to be careful
about how I do that stuff on my channel
so that's typically why I just try to
remind people to not post spoilers in
the comments regardless of what you
chose to do it's not that big a deal and
you probably remember last summer as
they started filming season seven people
were camping the set way more than ever
they sort of release pictures of Jon
Snow and Daenerys together so it became
this big thing where people are like do
we talk about spoilery stuff like we're
actually seeing stuff play out on screen
that we'll see during the season so it
became this big thing about how to
address potential production spoilers
because in the past we used to get a
casting video every summer from HBO at
Comic Con where it's like here's the
blackfish he's a new character that's
coming on during the season here the
sand snakes even though they became
really controversial so it's one thing
when HBO officially announces stuff
that's going to be happening next season
but there's a difference between knowing
that a character's going to be part of a
season in knowing like a complete plot
arc so that's usually where I try to
draw the line but the episode for leak
is pretty much identical to what
happened during season five when they
were like I think was four episodes or
maybe it was the first five episodes it
was actually a lot almost half of the
season leaked and I believe it was from
a South American server someone just
yanked it right off of there and
released it to the Internet so it's not
quite the same thing as the HBO hack
that's usually a ransom situation cyber
terrorism is a really big thing now
where somebody will hack a bank or you
may have heard about Netflix getting
hacked in them stealing a bunch of
episodes of oranges the new black if you
don't pay us the ransom money we're
going to release all these episodes into
the wild usually with HBO it's not a
ransom situation it's just people
finding a backdoor on somebody's old
computer with a really weak password and
saying oh hey here's an episode why
don't I take this and just upload it to
the internet so it's totally okay for
you guys to message me stuff and ask me
about things like this but depending on
the situation and how severe it is and
how big of an illegal sitch
it might wind up being usually I just
wind up having to back away slowly for
my computer and pretend like it doesn't
exist for a couple days the one
exception to that is situations like The
Avengers trailer so like they screens an
Avengers trailer at Comic Con but they
didn't release it into the wild so
people are like where's the infinity war
trailer but because I got to scene in
advance and they did actually show it to
people publicly then it's okay to talk
about but the HBO situation is an
episode that they didn't screen for
people it was meant to be private until
tomorrow so this is really fine line so
I try to be as careful as possible like
I don't want to do anything that's going
to prevent me from being able to make
videos in like 10 years like usually you
find people that leak stuff like this
they get banned pretty quickly so no
worries it's all good we'll talk all
about the episode we'll rip it apart
tomorrow when I post my episode 4 video
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Tom teresting I almost wanted to
say Hunter s Thompson please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details
there'll be a new giveaway winner when I
post that episode for video tomorrow
night believe all you request for bonus
videos before then in the comments below
there's a couple more videos I'm going
to try and get out today but while you
wait for everything you can click here
for my episode 4 trailer video and you
can click here for my episode 3 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you